the late Queen Elizabeth began riding
horses at three years old her father
George VI gave Elizabeth her first
personal horse a bushy Maine
done-colored Shetland named Peggy when
she was four
George VI unabashedly lived up to the
cliche that racing is the sport of Kings
he sought bought and bred quality racing
thoroughbreds when he died in 1952
Elizabeth inherited George's equestrian
operation the Royal studs at Sandringham
Norfolk in addition to inheriting the
king's Stables of Runners hacking horses
and hunters and thus she began her
immersive seven decade Odyssey into the
equine world how passionate a horse
woman was she
despite kovid and her increasing frailty
the queen hadn't skipped a Royal Windsor
Horse Show since its Inception in 1943
when she had to forego her usual
Walkabout for medical reasons she still
went to the horse show The Queen Is
perhaps best known to the British racing
public for leading the annual
spectacularly formal Landau Carriage
parade at the Royal Ascot meeting each
June and for running many of her horses
in the various Stakes over the week
during her 70-year Reign Elizabeth
missed attending just one Royal Ascot
the 2022 meeting this past June
beginning in the mid-1980s the queen
began sending many of her breeding
Stables mares to Kentucky to be bred to
top American thoroughbreds which are
horses that are considered to have
greater speed than British Racers the
Queen's Monumental work ethic as Monarch
applied to her level of study and
Devotion to her horses especially the
breeding and racing operations
last year at 95 she was begged by her
doctors to step back from her own riding
but after the Platinum Jubilee
celebrations in early June she continued
to ride her horses
Elizabeth II didn't quit anything if she
could help it not philanthropy not
government not public appearances not
her Christmas speech and certainly not
racing her horses won all the British
Classics ascot's Gold Cup epsom's Derby
the lot and she's been inducted into the
British racing Hall of Fame as
calculated from 1988 until 2022 Queen
Elizabeth's racers in all classes and on
all surfaces won her 8.7 million pounds
or about 10 million US Dollars she
entered her horses in
3441 races in the last 35 years winning
566 of them her most successful year was
2021 when she won 36 races of the 166
she had her horses enter proving that
horse racing could very easily be known
as the sport of Queens
with a characteristically sharp eye on
the bottom line she gave a lot to the
sport but also made it hay
[Music]